miss teen USA 2016 is Texas
newly crowned Miss Teen USA Carly hey is
being slammed after her win on Saturday
Chrissy Teigen was just one of many who
took to Twitter to react to the results
of the beauty pageant after seeing that
the top five finalists were all
Caucasian and blonde she tweeted on
Sunday Wow how can we choose from such a
diverse Bunch since Carly won the
coveted crown she's also received
backlash for old tweets that were
brought to the light angry Twitter users
pointed out that years ago the 18 year
old used the n-word frequently on her
personal account that is now set to
private Carly responded with a public
apology on the official Miss Texas teen
account explaining her past remarks
quote several years ago I had many
personal struggles and found myself in a
place that is not representative of Who
I am as a person I admit that i have
used language publicly in the past which
I am NOT proud of and that there is no
excuse for she added I am today a better
person I am honored to hold this title
and will use this platform to promote
the values of the Miss Universe
Organization and my own that recognized
the confidence beauty and perseverance
of all women
you